the red woman Melisandre has uttered
many memorable lines throughout
gameofthrones history this is coming for
everyone and everything the darkness
movie fans can always count on the
mystical priestess to deliver powerful
truce while propagating her faith in the
Lord of lights and changing the lives of
many for better and for worse
one such Westerosi who Melisandre has
crossed paths with is Arya Stark and on
the latest episode of Game of Thrones
the two women had a conversation as
ignited a fascinating theory about where
this series will go from here
just before Arya takes a flying leap
with a knight king and kills him with
her Valyrian steel dagger and just after
beric bravely sacrifices his life to
save is as she's overwhelmed by whites
in the corridors of Winterfell she meets
with Melisandre for a mid-battle chat
this isn't the first time Milla Sondra
and I are spoken the first encounter
they had was on the third season of
Thrones a Melisandre prophesied arias
future brown eyes blue eyes green eyes
eyes you'll shut forever
[Music]
we will meet again Aria did indeed shut
many eyes forever before finally
slaughtering the night king a move which
also killed his entire army when she and
Melisandre met again Aria confirmed that
the priest s can actually see the future
he said I shot many eyes forever you're
right about that brown eyes green eyes
and blue eyes
ah Aria went to kill the blue-eyed night
king thus sealing shut a second set of
eyes but what about the third eye color
Melisandre mentioned many fans believe
that those green eyes belong to none
other than Cersei Lannister and the Arya
will murder the mad Queen when she and
the survivors of the Battle of
Winterfell arrive in King's Landing on
the next episode of Game of Thrones
Circe's eyes are definitely green
described by author george RR martin as
a perfect match to the emeralds of a
tiara she once wore actress Lena Headey
- has green eyes however astute fans
will recall that iron has already killed
someone with green eyes Littlefinger his
peepers are said to be great green and
cat-like in Martin's A Song of Ice and
Fire book series though actor Aidan
Gillen XY's a blue in real life if Arya
does have more green eyes to close what
she actually killed the Emerald eyed
Cersei the mad Queen is one of a few
names left on arias hit list standing
with the Hound on the mountain so
there's not exactly a lack of desire to
murder her and arias part there's also a
strong chance that Arya might murder
Jaime Lannister says his twin who shares
her eye color and implement the
technique she learned at the house of
black and white and Braavos to disguise
herself as Jaime and kill Cersei such an
actor would connect to another major
Game of Thrones prophecy the one says he
received in a youth in a season five
flashback fortune-teller Maggy the Frog
told Cersei that she would marry a king
he would father twenty children and she
would give birth to three and her
children would each taste power before
dying while she was still alive in
Martin's novels the conversation
continues a Maggie tells Cersei that she
will eventually be overcome with grief
and pain at that time as she will be
murdered by a balun car the word for
little brother in high Valyrian sir sees
other sibling Tyrion could be the little
brother who murders her especially given
that he spent the knee to the Narus
however valonqar means little brother
and not littlest meaning that Jaime he
was born minutes after Cersei could also
be the one to kill her or at least
someone who looks just like him Arya
stealing Jamie's face to do the deed
would be a surprise twist for viewers
and might even link up to Maggie's
mention that a younger and more
beautiful Queen will cast
you down and take all that she holds
dear perhaps Daenerys will be the one to
ask Aria to murder Jamie as revenge for
the Lannister man slaying her father
during Robert's rebellion then Arya
might snatch Jamie's mug fulfill maggy's
prophecy by murdering Cersei as Jaime
and clear the Iron Throne for Daenerys
to take since few predicted that Arya
would even kill the knight King on the
latest episode there really is no saying
I'll sound these series are or
anticipating what exactly will happen
next hopefully the next episode of Game
of Thrones will clear up any lingering
questions about Arya and Milla Sandra's
conversation and reveal whether Cersei
will live to see another day check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about Game of
Thrones are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]
you
[Music]